this question was submitted by a member
of the Electrical and Electronics
Engineers magnetics community the
question is what area of research in
magnetism and spin related research
could lead to breakthroughs in the next
ten years spent only expanded in so many
directions so is difficult to choose
them but I can select two directions
spin turning with carbon-based material
or a graphene this material seems the
best for a spin transport to long
distance say well above the micron henge
and so the most promising for
application in electronics for exam for
the treatment of an information based on
spin guns and not long no longer on
charged ions and among the very exciting
leadership today will cite also what is
called the topological insulator so new
type of materials new state of matter i
can say that give rise to non DC TV
current on the edges of some quantum
wells of some materials and this is also
a very exciting direction obtaining non
dissipative spin currents in this
quantum spin Hall effect materials